you could say speaker of the house nancy
pelosi has been in the spotlight since
the day
she was born her birth front page news
in baltimore
where her father was a congressman at
the time pelosi's political education
and evolution
into the most powerful woman in american
political history
is the subject of a new biography madam
speaker nancy pelosi and the lessons of
power is by usa today
washington bureau chief susan page who
joins us now
susan good morning to you the most
powerful woman in american political
history i think you could probably drop
political
just say the most powerful woman in
american history
she is second in line to the presidency
twice elected speaker of the house
and a difficult interview she comes on
this program she says what she wants to
say and nothing more
what surprised you in your 10
conversations with her for this book
well one thing that was that that was
great in these 10 interviews was
that i think she came to trust me a
little more relax a little more
i interviewed her just last week for usa
today
and she talked about the events of
january 6 with some candor she said that
she thought that in fact that mob on
january 6 didn't tend to
kill her but if they had caught her they
would have had a battle on their hands
because she's a street fighter
then she lifted up her foot pointed to
her four
inch stilettos and said she would have
used these
as weapons so she is a tough interview
but also such an interesting
consequential
person in american history highly
consequential she almost walked away
from politics in 2016 and then as the
story goes donald trump is elected and
she decided to stay
what do you think that meant for her
legacy and in those four years of
battles that we all witnessed who do you
think
came out with the better part of it well
i'll just say that donald trump is back
in mar-a-lago in a forced retirement
and nancy pelosi is still the speaker of
the house
uh you know it was as though it was in
her entire career of these decades
at the center of power where preparation
for her to become
the democratic face of the opposition
to donald trump i think really burnished
her reputation and made i think
some americans realize how important she
had been previously not perhaps gotten
all the credit that she had deserved
she has been reelected speaker at a time
when the incoming was not only from
those on the right
in political attack ads and in speeches
but also those
on the left how has she been able to
balance the two
well she's done it with some skill you
know she is herself a very liberal
person
she's a new deal kind of democrat but
she thinks that
understands that it's a democratic
members of the house
from swing districts that have given
democrats the majority and the ability
to get things done and that's how she's
navigated
that very narrow threat you know at the
moment she can only choose she can only
lose two
democratic votes and get things through
this very partisan
this very partisan house that leaves her
almost no wiggle room
to hold these wings of the party
together yeah one of the amazing things
about madam speaker is she did not enter
politics until she was in her late 40s i
believe 47 had already
raised five children but clearly had
learned the lessons of power which is
the subtitle of the book
what is the biggest lesson would you say
from the career of nancy pelosi
yes there's a lesson she learned from
her father who served three terms as the
mayor of baltimore it was
no one is going to give you power you
have to seize it
and while she was late to running for
office herself once she was there
that is a precept she has followed it is
advice she has given to other
politicians it has made her gain power
hold power
and wield power and she has been very
effective at it
susan page thank you very much the book
is madam speaker it is on sale
today pick it up